- I gotta ask you though.
Is it true that you ended
up moving in with your
parents during the pandemic?
- [Nikki] Yes,
and it was for you, too,
I have you to thank.
- [Kelly] Why?
- I was about to be on your show.
- Oh yes!
- And COVID hit, and my mom was out here
to appear on the show with me.
And so we were already together
and I go, you know,
everything's shutting down.
Let me just go back to
St. Louis with my parents.
I'm already with them so
I can't contaminate them.
We'll go back. I'll wait this
thing out till it blows over.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- [Nikki] And as we
know, it really didn't.
- [Kelly] For like a minute.
- I lived with them for
10 months in St. Louis.
- So do your parents wanna thank me
or do they wanna not thank me.
(audience laughing)
- They have some words,
Kelly, but it was fun.
- But that's cool though,
cause we don't get time like that
usually with family, that's cool.
- [Nikki] And I have cool parents,
like they're really fun.
And by that, I mean
alcoholic, but I just...
(audience laughing)
No, I actually, I shouldn't,
I shouldn't do that joke,
cause my mom just quit
talking to me and, so....
(Kelly laughing)
No, they're great. I
eventually had to move out
because it was so
embarrassing, cause I liked it.
And the real reason I
lived at home is because I,
you know, I don't have a husband.
I didn't have like anyone else.
- [Kelly] To like quarantine with, yeah.
- Yeah. And I didn't wanna be alone.
And so I was just...
- I think it's cool.
- [Nikki] Thank you.
- Yeah.
- I felt embarrassed though,
because people kept asking,
you know, usually you live
at home with your parents
if things aren't going well.
So people are just like,
'you're successful. You're 37.
Why are you living with your mom and dad?'
So I got rid of that therapist
and I was just like,
(audience laughing)
let's just not go into it.
- Let's just leave it alone.
- [Nikki] Yeah, like we
don't need to go in there.
- [Kelly] Like, why would
we need to resurface that?
- Yes
- (laughs) I love you so much.
So wait, I have to talk
about this because now
you're hosting FBoy Island.
- Yes.
- So what exactly is an Fboy?
- It is, the F honestly
stands for fragile.
(audience laughing)
It's like, Fboys are guys
that haven't addressed
their childhood trauma,
the anger they have
towards women or themselves.
And then they lie to women
to get to sleep with them
or get something out of them.
Cause they don't have enough self-esteem,
like, that's what it comes down to.
- You are a therapist.
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Kelly] That's what's happening here.